all right so let's take a look now at  our daily coronavirus numbers and this  one's really concerning right here  1200 new cases and eight deaths reported  just overnight the test positivity  continues to each  an inch up standing at 10.3 percent  and cases are nearing a hundred thousand  here statewide  since march uh clark county meantime  reporting a bulk of those cases an  increase of 890 cases  seven deaths the southern nevada health  district says the increase  is expected with the trend of high  community transmission  as more people continue to get tested  the recovery rate those stands are  pretty steady there at 90 percent